this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your money your
relationships your mental wellness
your job your career all of its game
it's all about your life and that's what
we do here on the ramsey show every day
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five two two five o'dell is
with us in fairfax virginia hey odell
welcome to the ramsey show
hey good afternoon gentlemen i
appreciate you guys taking my call i've
actually been a pretty long time
follower so i i do appreciate this well
thank you we're honored to have you how
can we help
um i was recently offered a new position
as a software developer with a new
company that's willing to pay me 25 000
more than my current position with the
company i'm with wow conflicted whether
or not i should stay with my company
since my experience in software
development is relatively new and i was
also in the marine corps so i have this
weird sense of loyalty as this being the
first job that i got out once i got out
of the service yeah um and i'm just
feeling really conflicted
well let's just say this loyalty is not
weird and thank you for your service
it's great
it's a rare and it's a good thing so
glad you have it yeah thank you for your
service as well um
the issue is if
if you weren't loyal it's just loyalty
is great but let's just look at the path
forward for you
this company has clearly offered you a
job because they think you can do it
whether or not you think you have the
experience or not
and so you have to ask yourself
what's the best path for me if i stay at
my current company and continue to do a
good job are they talking about a path
are they showing me a path do i see a
path forward
you have to look at all of those things
but you know it doesn't make you
disloyal
by taking another great opportunity it's
all in how you handle yourself and i
think you're a
a high character individual and that's
why you're wrestling with this am i a
bad guy
if i leave to take another
opportunity but you have to first say is
it the right opportunity it may not be
the right opportunity it might be a 25
000 race but a horrible culture
because if you take the 25 000 raise and
it's a horrible culture and they don't
treat people the way that maybe your
current company's treating let me tell
you something the 25 000 pay pump is
going to wear off pretty quickly about
20 seconds that's right so you're going
to have to look at this holistically
first of all what's right is it right
beyond the twenty five thousand dollar
pay bump yeah odell i'm from the uh
proud noble hillbilly culture and we
value loyalty that's right like no other
culture no not really but i mean we do
value loyalty it's a big deal and uh
many years ago when the 100 years ago
when the internet was first invented i
had a young man working for me that came
to me and said we need a website and i
said what is that and he said if you'll
send me to a class for twenty five
hundred dollars so i can learn coal
fusion which no one uses anymore um we i
can build you a website and you can
actually people will buy stuff on it i
went yeah right how much is the way how
much is the uh the cut training 2500 and
i was paying the guy 35 000 bucks a year
he was an assistant inside the
organization there was just a few of us
there's probably 40 of us 30 of us and
um his daughter had cystic fibrosis
and so he's constantly dealing with
challenges at home medical bills
constantly fighting through this stuff
and he went and got
um
cold fusion training i paid 2 500 for
him to go to oklahoma city paid for the
airfare paid six weeks later of course
the internet is starting to become a
thing dave was the last to be told this
but um
uh i mean it was blowing up a guy walks
in i was paying him 35 000 offered him a
hundred and thirty five thousand because
he was he knew cold fusion sure
and i had just paid for his coal fusion
so odell let me tell you what i did i
helped him pack his desk
his daughter has cystic fibrosis i'm not
paying the guy 135 000 in those days to
do that uh and so i i said my friend i
love you take this job
and he was grateful to me he was
conflicted like you were conflicted but
i cared about him as a person and as a
dad and i told him to go take the job i
did not consider him disloyal for
bringing me that uh a situation and
you're not disloyal son you're a good
man yeah
yeah
you just gotta look at the big picture
is this the right move now here's what
happens
there's we got to remember our humanness
when somebody number one offers us a
position from outside
there's two things that happen number
one we all feel wanted and that feels
nice oh you want me it's like being
picked on the playground nobody ever
wanted to be the last person picked
something about the value there the
second thing that happened to me all the
time
but the second was never any good at
dodgeball well but dave you've done it
and it well it's proven that all i got
in the head a bunch apparently well
maybe it helped you become who you are
careful yeah watch out too close too
soon and then the other thing that
happens is the money piece
so i feel good when somebody wants me
but the second thing that happens is it
seems like the smart thing to do why
wouldn't i take what am i going to sell
out
and then you start to go wait a person
of honor yeah you start to feel what i'm
saying
am i a sellout is it all am i that guy
yeah that it's all about the money and
you're not that here's an interesting
thing that guy never asked that question
that's exactly right and so this is a
good man number one number two realize
this that it's all the way you handle
yourself leave with class yeah lots of
gratitude thank you for the opportunity
you've been amazing just like you said
to the marine corps when you walked out
of there you said thank you you helped
me get to be where i am you guys thank
you you helped me to get to where i am
i'm moving on to the next season in my
life clark is in salt lake city hey
clark what's up in your world
hey how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
yeah quick question um so my wife and i
are in a little bit of a car bind um
kelly blue book suggested the value of
the car is around fifty six hundred
dollars
but the issue is that um
it's at the shop and
you learn that it's gonna require around
four thousand dollars in repairs to get
it good lord working again did you take
it to the dealer yeah
that is at the dealer yeah because the
check engine light was on yeah and you
know that dealer that's not a good place
to get your car fixed right
you know you know it's double what
everybody else is right
honestly i i've always been someone that
just takes it to the dealer no
well i'm getting ready to help you with
that now you're not
because now you're someone that wants a
better deal than they'll give you so i
want you to get a second opinion on this
from someone else what's wrong with the
car
um
i mean it's only
it's a 2012 102 000 miles the turbo i
guess is out the oil
coolers out the axle seal
on the drive side is
leaking
well on a 5000 car we don't worry about
the axle seal you're not going to be
driving it that much longer we certainly
don't care about the turbo well yeah if
you can fix it but i mean so i want you
to get a second opinion if the net
result is that you can get it fixed for
three thousand would i fix a fifty six
hundred dollar car for three thousand no
i would not i'd sell it
okay so you have the four thousand you
have the four thousand dollars
do you have the four thousand dollars to
fix the car
yes put that with the money you get from
selling the car as is and buy you
another car
because you're probably going to get
1600 for it as is
or better
do you think it's better to just list it
as is with the issues and see what i can
get for it i think you'll get couple
thousand bucks for it
and you put that with four thousand
bucks you've got a six thousand dollar
car that's not broken
i would do that before i'd spend four
thousand dollars on a six thousand
dollar car now i would get a second
opinion and i would quit going to the
dealer for major repairs until you're
rich
because you really can't afford it until
then what must be done for this car to
operate that would be the question i'd
ask with the second and third opinion
too yeah this is a hooptie so let's just
hoop we don't need to we don't need a
race
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host triple h
five five
two two five
we're having a lengthy uh good old boy
discussion at the break about car
repairs um so let's just bleed that on
over to the microphones for a second
because it's a good principle we get we
tell folks drive a cheap car drive like
no one else so later you can drive like
no one else live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else pay a price i drove a piece of crap
now i don't drive a piece of crap
because i don't have to because i don't
have car payments i've never had car
payments in the last 30 years and that
means i have money
whoa it's a neat formula
and so i did i drive a hooptie for uh
ever no i drove it for a year
and i got a little better hooptie that
really was not just a quasi-hooptie and
then i moved up a year later into a
non-hooptie and from then on i never
looked back and bought used cars until i
had a net worth of a million dollars and
i paid cash for my cars and anything
with a motor or wheels in it
because they go down in value i know not
lately but it's the one time in the
history of the vehicle that it has not
gone out down in value and it will
return people and that's not just a
boomer it's an economic prediction
called supply demand curve okay anyway
now what do you do if you're driving a
hoop d and it breaks a lot of our people
are driving thousand dollar cars 500
cars garage sale car right 2 000 car
okay these are throwaway cars
they will bring almost as much at the
junkyard not running
as they will running on craigslist
okay because it's a garage sale car and
anything 5 000 or under is in this
category most of those cars you do not
do major repairs to no because it's not
worth it so here's the way the formula
works if you can sell the car in his
case for sixteen hundred dollars
and you put four thousand dollars in it
and the car is worth fifty six hundred
you broke even
if you could sell the car for two
thousand dollars and you put four
thousand dollars in it and you sell it
for fifty six hundred you lost four
hundred dollars
so if the value of the car as is
plus the repair
the actual repair not from a dealer plus
the repair
is more than the finished fixed value
don't fix it yep and usually if it's a
major multi thousand dollar repair
that's what you're going to find because
you're not increasing the value of the
car now if you've got a car it's worth
500 bucks and you put 500 bucks in it
and it's worth 4 thousand dollars
hey you'd probably do that one right
yeah even if you turn around and sell it
yeah i'll give you that i'll give you a
real life situation as dave is breaking
this down not too long ago we just did
this i was driving an older lexus of
2006 had 185 000 miles on running great
folks i don't do a lot of driving so i
was i was coming back and forth here and
i've got a kid who's going to be 16 and
so we're looking at well do we keep it
for him transmission starts to go
alright so i go all right now i do
little repairs by the way now this is
the ken coleman rule if you like a
little risk and you got an emergency
fund every time the check engine light
came on i was like
how bad could it be
so eventually i'd take it in and just
like that caller they'd give me a list
of 17 things and i was really good at
going all right if this were your car
what do i need to fix that gets me a to
b this is several years ago and they
reset the computer and turn the check
engine light off yeah you'd be surprised
all right so the story goes the
transmission starts to go dave so here's
the deal it's going to be 3 800
which i have to fix that transmission
but my kid's 15 he's huge and i was like
ty do you want this he's like i can
barely get in it so we now realized what
i would have had he wanted that car had
he fit in the car i probably would have
because the car probably worth about
seven all right i would have done it for
his first car because if he wrecks it
i'm not worried about it but he didn't
want it so i flipped it
bad transmission full disclosure 2500
bucks cash yeah it's exactly what we did
a few not too long ago so take that cash
and what you would have spent on the
transmission and buy him up something he
can fit in because he's a big football
player that's it yeah all right there
you go
yeah this is the formula robert is in
utah hi robert welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thanks for taking my call guys
good how can we help
well i'm
curious about i bonds i see the new
savings rate on the i-bond is seven
percent
which is pretty rock-solid from what
i've been getting recently
but uh i was curious on your thoughts on
that and then secondary to that kind of
where to fund that
fund it out of roth ira or
take a little bit out of the 12-month
savings that i have so just curious on
your thoughts
okay well we tell folks to have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
and uh is it is it you know is it
available is it liquid and i keep mine
in a money market account not 12 months
three to six months
um seven percent is a great rate of
return on something like a bond
you're right
and it's certainly safe as an investment
because it's the united states
government as much as we make fun of
them it's safe
i mean we make fun of how dumb they are
and how much money they spend and all
that stuff but and it's all true the
things we would say about them we make
fun of them but they're not going broke
okay and so we the people are going to
pay your stupid eye bond so um you know
you're safe with it if you want some
money parked at seven percent uh that's
an okay medium play it's not a good
long-term play
so you would not use it for your
retirement plans because your retirement
plans have to outpace taxes
and
inflation if the retirement plan is
taxable
if it's not taxable if it's a roth it
has to outpace inflation
lately seven percent won't do that
over the scope of 70 years inflation has
averaged about 4.2 percent according the
consumer price index which is the
measure of inflation
that's what everyone's using in the past
12 months when everybody's screaming
about inflation's out of control we're
all going to die
and um
all the drama that you're hearing on
news channels
all day long and it's real i mean it is
real the you know stuff's gone up but if
you have an inflation if you don't make
six or seven percent on your money with
taxes and inflation
overall in a normal economy you don't
break even
and so you want to invest north of 10
percent to make what's called a real
rate of return an economist calls it a
real rate of return which is tax which
is a rate of return above inflation
above taxes
and so what did you really make after
they those after the loaf of bread went
up double
and
uh you had to pay uncle on on the money
you took out and so it's okay if you
want to park some money there because
seven percent is pretty sexy in a liquid
investment right now it's not a good
long-term play and it's not the play for
your emergency fund so if you've got
some money for a medium play like the
money in excess of six months between 6
and 12 you said 12 you might play it
there jessica is in fort worth texas hi
jessica how are you
hi hi dave and ken it's an honor to
speak with you you too um i'm a big fan
and um my question for you is i'll try
to keep it brief and let you ask
questions so my husband and i are in
baby steps four five and six
we are high income earners we um we
gross about five hundred thousand
dollars a year i love you what do you
make
what do you do for a living what do you
guys do
um
i i work a couple of jobs that i'm a
physician and my husband works in
graphic design oh good okay
now well i'm glad you're doing so well
congratulations
well thank you that wasn't true a couple
years ago and then we followed your plan
and paid off all of our debt may of last
year wow and we paid off over half a
million dollars wow
the typical mistakes that physicians
make
and and now we've dug ourselves out of
the hole so we are very grateful for you
teaching us that well thank you
well thank you um so my question for you
is about
investing i know that you usually
recommend match before roth or
traditional
i do not think we will be making as much
money in retirement as we do now
so my husband and i are wondering if we
should do traditional before
no because you will be making as much
money as you make now the reason is the
size of your investment account is going
to create an income that's in excess of
what you make now
okay you're gonna have so stinking much
money you make a lot of money how old
are you
i'm 36. okay i mean you systematically
invest a hundred thousand dollars a year
for the next 30 years
and we're talking about 50 million
dollars
my numbers don't come out that high i'm
gonna use your name i'm i'm making that
up but i'm not i mean it's north of 20
it's between 20 and 50.
yeah yeah it's high yeah it's a lot um
and so the the investment returns on
that are going to approach your current
income and we have no way to predict
what the freaking tax rates are going to
be
when the island of misfit toys gets
through playing up there
um yeah no i'm i'm still doing roth i'm
still doing match to roth
i make good money too i make more than
you do and i'm still doing roth first
before traditional in fact i don't have
anything in traditional i want it all to
be tax free
tax-free growth tax-free growth tax free
growth you really want to be tax-free
when you have a lot of money
that's a good thing because you don't
want the taxes because it pisses you off
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Applause]
guys i got to tell you i'm so excited
we're on the road again to uh quote the
famous song right
oh man ramsey solutions is hitting the
road you already know our building
wealth live event is coming to las vegas
in orlando this may
we're excited to share a few more cities
that we're headed to this fall uh get
ready sacramento
minneapolis san antonio and more we're
coming for you
at building wealth we'll tackle the
latest get rich quick trends dive deep
into investing saving planning for
retirement
what might sound like a lot of
complicated stuff truth is it's way
easier than you think me rachel cruz
george campbell will be there along with
ken coleman dr john delony
we'll be signing books taking photos
answering questions doing the event
and uh all of us will have something to
say to you on this subject so be ready
so las vegas orlando sacramento
minneapolis san antonio we'd love to see
you vegas as may 9.
orlando is may 19th sacramento just
announcing this week november 1 november
10 is minneapolis and san antonio's
november 15. so it's going to be a busy
spring a busy fall tickets are only 25
you can get a four pack for 60. bring a
couple of your friends it's only 15
bucks ahead come on you spend more than
that on pizza go to ramseysolutions.com
events get your tickets before they're
gone these first two spring events are
very close to selling out they're not
yet you still get your tickets but if
you screw around in a couple more weeks
you're gonna miss it so jump in there
ramsey solutions dot com slash events
oakland california with a debt-free
scream jeffrey and michelle
are with us hey guys how are you hi hi
how much have you guys paid off
120 000
yo how long did that take
uh four years and two months all right
good for you very cool and uh what was
your range of income during that time
we started at about 103 000 a year
and now we're at 176. way to go guys wow
what do y'all do for a living
i'm a teacher
and i work for a bay area transit
authority okay very cool what what grade
do you teach michelle i teach first
grade the little guys i love it good for
you
wow very cool i'm a superstar today
because i'm going to be on the radio
well you are a superstar you paid off
120 000 bucks that qualifies
yeah all right tell us the story what
happened four years and two months ago
put you on this journey
we had dabbled a little bit in some
envelopes because we had heard cds a
friend lend that lended us several years
ago
but we didn't get real serious until our
church had a financial peace university
class
and we sat down and really started the
form of the first things you do is tally
up how much you're in debt
and
it was kind of shocking
scared the crud out of you huh yeah it
did because we're older and we need i
couldn't see myself at 80 years old
with student loans still yeah you know
so
we were in an all-fired hurry to get it
done at that point right yeah so so you
went through the class and that got you
going hardcore right yes
yes
way to go real serious we kept the
envelopes religiously we named every
penny
i mean we sold stuff we rolled change
and we took lots of walks and hikes ate
sandwiches in the parks
sounds like you were healthier
yes
that too wow good for you well done you
guys so thanks jeffrey michelle so it
sounds like you guys went all in pretty
quickly on this were there some hiccups
or were there some things that were
really really hard as you began this
process of gazelle intensity
yes
tell me about
it well it was just like i said we just
really worked hard at making sure that
we
you know followed the steps
and
make sure that it really is interesting
was the fact that um
um we some of the challenges were you
know i i had our time sticking to the
changes and some of us wanted to do you
know she had our time with you know
paying the smallest interest
first in the baby steps and stuff
and then but i i
found in the last year or two especially
it was oregon it was fun once we paid
off a debt it was like
a high okay we want to get to the next
one
you know and so that seemed to be the
big kicker is you know all right what's
the next one and how fast can we get
pertained off that seemed to be the fun
that became our entertainment was okay
let's knock out the first one as fast as
possible right
that worked dave i'll tell you dave and
ken um for me
it was really hard because i was used to
being taught you pay the high interest
things first
and it was a total
change and i consider it a personal um
championship moment that i convinced a
first grade teacher to do something
because first grade teachers are
hardcore man i mean
you guys have a system you stick to it
if i got you to do it i'd get anybody to
do it that's awesome you got it you got
it but then getting me to pay those
small ones first
not the high interest it was a change of
thinking and
it took a while for me to wrap my head
around it but i did it yeah and then and
then when they started going away you
started going oh yeah yeah that snowball
gets really exciting
i love it yes
i'm so proud of you guys what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
just being patient
[Music]
being patient and kind for you kind to
yourself
forgiving yourself and jumping back on
yeah
that sounds like you fell off
um not really we'd have a month or two
we're gonna got a little slippery but no
okay let's tighten it up we're getting a
little sloppy here you know um instead
of letting it carry us away we kind of
had to yeah because you do when you slip
like that you either finish falling off
or you grab hold and pull back up right
right that's more of what we did we
would like okay oh we're we're pulling
out this we're doing this uh thing wrong
here let's get back on the horse and get
back to where we are supposed to be and
we said a lot of this what would dave
say exactly
my shaming voice in your head
i love her laugh i wish everybody
responded to what would dave say with
that laugh it doesn't usually have that
much harmony and
melody and happiness usually people
curse his name you're just like
hilarious i love that
you guys are amazing we're so proud of
you hey we got a copy of the uh
baby steps millionaires for you because
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure you're on your way to doing
that
very well done everybody at ramsey
congratulate you we will send you a high
five from nashville we'll also send you
a copy of total money makeover you can
give it to someone and get their journey
started like you have uh like it has for
eight million plus people now in these
days so way to go you guys very very
very proud of you so much
all right jeffrey and michelle oakland
california a first grade teacher did it
120 000 paid off in four years and two
months making 103 to 176. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
one two
[Music]
[Applause]
three i love it
so coleman the babylon bee has gotten in
a lot of trouble in a couple of
instances with their satire oh yes
people uh cancel culture has been
jumping on them we've been following the
babylon b since before it was a thing
it was just a thing making fun of a
a bunch of christians making fun of a
bunch of christians it was hilarious
stuff and it has now expanded a little
bit so since they began i mean like
their first
i don't know five or six satirical
articles one of them was aimed at me oh
yeah and they are funny very funny
they're fun they rip dave ramsey to
shreds and it is funny they're not mean
mean about it they're mean about some
people but they're not really mean to me
well they're not yeah they don't rip you
to shreds they're playing everything is
sad but they're just making fun of me
it's so funny though they're so they
posted one last week and my guys brought
it to me a while ago dave ramsey stars
in new show to catch a borrower oh it's
called to catch a borrower yeah where he
catches christians trying to buy things
on a credit card it's got a picture of
me peeking up from behind the couch
while the guy's on his computer buying
stuff
oh two phones play off of to catch a
predator i guess yeah and it says
i call the guy a freaking idiot
have i done that that sounds familiar
that would be funny to see you pop up in
people's living rooms that could cause
some blood pressure issues for sure it
caused you to get shot
just popping up randomly in someone's
living room sounds like a good way
that's the concept
yeah so the way to go babylon b we
salute you it's funny we love you guys
keep it up keep making fun of everybody
including yourself it's awesome
everybody needs to lighten up a notch
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825-5225
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five cody is with us in indiana
hi cody welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave
yeah
kind of nervous not gonna lie
no trouble we've never lost a patient
you're gonna make it
um
so i'm a general contractor uh debt-free
uh me and my wife got about a hundred
and four thousand dollars of capital
and
i hate people so i want to work for
myself rather than a client
and uh
so my long-term goal has been wanting to
get into flipping houses that way i can
just
let them sell and be done i gotta mess
with anybody
but
i've not gotten into it yet and with
everything going on the way it is i'm
kind of uh
worried about starting at the moment
okay
i gotta ask dave how are you gonna be a
general contractor my father-in-law is
very successful at it and not deal with
some people i get your general uh you
mean you don't wanna deal with clients
nitpicking your work
no i well
that always happens
regardless
you can work for 100 different people 90
of them
are not so great right that's about
average
yeah it's just uh
being the owner i'm constantly running
through the run to the stores
all the time
and i just want to be able to work
you're going to do all the work yourself
are you going to sub it out
uh
i'd say about what i could i mean i
don't want to cut in my costs of course
but i don't do everything i don't do
hvac i'm not licensed for that of course
okay so what about i'm with ken i don't
mind answering your question but i'm
just curious because there's times i
agree with you i love people but they
also about two percent of them should be
institutionalized so um
you know they just they're nutty and
they're on twitter and so um what what
what is it uh what people are you
cutting out by doing this process
well a client i don't have to go uh do
bids for people and then do their work i
can just
100 work for myself okay
until you sell the house and they're of
course going to want you to do
to finish up or to
fix whatever is broken after they move
in right you know that
unfortunately yeah that's going to go so
you're not cutting them out completely
but you're getting rid of a lot of the
back and forth while you're doing the
job that's what you're after okay i'm
with you on that right now let's go back
to your question flipping houses well
we're in a white hot real estate market
everybody knows that right so very tough
to buy deals and part of flipping a
house or making money is you have to buy
it at a deal
oh yeah absolutely and so what you've
got to be very very careful of is a no
debt
b
be so patient
that you pass on 50 deals
to get one
that works
okay
i i used to buy before i went broke i
made a really good living
and and
buying and selling foreclosures i was
doing flips before chip and joanna were
born okay
and so um
but i looked at in those days i looked
at 200 deals to buy one that was my
average
because i was gonna because all the
money in real estate on flips is made at
the buy
if you buy a property and the weird
crazy white hot market where people are
paying too much is the only way you get
out of it and make money you didn't buy
the property right
yes you need to buy it at
70
72 73 of appraisal
today minus repairs
yes and then you can actually make a
profit because you're going to lose 12
percent on the resale in commissions
closing costs and negotiation off of
appraisal
unless you catch the edge of a white hot
market which we're in right now okay but
if you depend on a white hot market to
bail out your bad deal you're gonna get
your butt burned
yeah that's what i don't want to happen
yeah
cheap or don't buy
and buy with debt and have a formula
minus repairs so uh you know you gotta
let's use a round number you had a
hundred thousand dollar house you're
gonna buy it for seventy two seventy
three thousand dollars it makes ten
thousand dollars worth of repairs means
you're gonna buy it for sixty two
thousand how you're gonna find that in
this world today you might find it
because it might be so messed up nobody
else wants it because it's so freaking
ugly
that even a white hot market won't sell
this white elephant
okay
but they're very hot deals are hard to
find right now
and foreclosures are not happening at
the level that they were happening
because there's been a whole bunch of
people still sitting on the foreclosures
due to the moratoriums they're just
starting to re-enter the market so a
little harder to find the foreclosure
deals too
uh right now maybe by the end of summer
they will have opened back up so if
you're patient and you just say
you know don't don't get all hot and
bothered about buying something and you
buy it at a deal minus repairs and you
get paid to do the repairs and then you
get paid on the transaction as a profit
both things
then and you do it with no debt then
you're going to be okay
so but that's going to involve a lot of
work of finding a deal and it's very
difficult to do right now
and there's people out there flipping
houses right now and they're depending
on white hot market to bail them out and
that market's going to turn off on them
and they're going to get caught holding
that so cody dave just gave you the
formula so now you have to ask the
question how much money must i have so
what needs to be true do i need 200 000
in cash 250 to be able to get that kind
of a deal with that ratio and then make
money on it because remember you're
making really good money in your
business right now i suspect yeah and so
if you're going to switch over to
full-time flipper then you got to play
that equation out how many houses would
i have to flip to pay myself what i make
you've given him a wonderful formula now
he's going to have to be patient that's
what's going on 104 000 to invest in
flipping that um
three times a year maybe
you're probably building some houses
still yeah that's why you're right take
some time while you're running these
flips you could run both at the same
time but having until you build your
capital up and you could get two or
three flips going at a time that's
correct with actual dollars then when
you get there you could probably step
aside from doing the contracting but
you're probably still going to do a
little contracting and that will also
calm you down and you don't get
desperate oh i got to get a house
because i got to get income and then
that's going to cause you to pay too
much
the name of the game in this is a
patience yes you know
i had a guy a mortgage company used to
buy property from after they took it
back one of these little finance
companies and he goes ramsey you're a
vulture
you're the nicest vulture i know
but you're a vulture
well you're right i'm kind of circling
waiting on something to die you know
that's what i'm doing you know i'm
because i'm looking for a deal i'm not
mad at anybody i'm not causing anybody
any harm i'm just going to help out when
they're there and i write a check and
buy the property but that was a long
time ago it's kind of a nice compliment
in a way it was in there it's in there
somewhere dave ramsey looking for that
real estate roadkill
that's the name of the new book real
estate real estate roadkill there it is
who knew
i was looking for a title ken
this is what i do but you know it's
funny you know you you gave you gave
cody some great advice i love that
formula and then you said it's all about
patience in cody's world he needs some
patience with all those people he hates
[Laughter]
just for a
i get what he's saying though he's he's
working with clients that are just
nitpicking and driving bananas we uh
yeah i i was in the custom home building
business as a sales guy for a while and
he's right you know about nine out of
ten of them are just the greatest people
in the world but let me tell you who
drives you absolutely nuts ones are too
broke to bite ah right so now they're
trying and and so they're trying to flex
up
you know and they go through the house
and they nitpick stuff right doesn't
even like scripping's gonna fix their
problems
you know like you know you're still
going to be broke after you flex over
this drywall piece of drywall right here
you know classic yeah one guy went
through with a magic marker and he had
the plan wrong in his hand he had it
backward and he drew on the wall where
the plugs were supposed to be instead of
where they were oh boy yeah we charged
him like ten thousand dollars to go
through we had to sand and seal and then
repaint every one of those walls and
cover that stupid magic marker that this
person so i get it i get it i get it i
understand i mean that guy the magic
marker guy that'll drive you out of the
business right there that would and so
um yeah you've got to manage those
people and manage their expectations in
the process and it's
um it's a challenge in that world it
really is so
yeah because people start building their
dream home and by the time it's done
their dream changed
yeah who knew
it's my forever home until it's not
forever
because nothing's forever
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your jobs we talk about
your career we talk about your money we
talk about your relationships your
mental wellness your life is discussed
every day here on
the ramsey show the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five
one of the things we have taught you
since we began around here
was a take off of the scripture in
hebrews it says no discipline seems
pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
now the way we've been saying that
around here is if you live like no one
else
later you can live and give
like no one else you have to pay a price
to win no discipline is pleasant at the
time you have to pay a price to win but
then when you go win
and you're outrageously generous now
you're really really really winning and
that's how it works
however
ken are you aware
that in our culture today
that rich people
are greedy horrible people rich people
are awful
if you build wealth you are a horrible
human being yes even if you're generous
with it you prove that you're a
hypocrite yes you are awful you must the
only way to build wealth is to screw
people over yes on the backs of the less
fortunate you have to you know and
always poor people don't need to screw
poor people because they have more money
for you to get wait a minute i'm now
confused but
yeah you have to make all your money on
the backs of poor people and you're
greedy rich people greedy rich people
they don't pay enough in taxes they
gotta pay their fair share unfair the
greedy rich people are everywhere so
james our producer came up with the idea
that we need to do a greedy rich people
segment and periodically expose
these greedy horrible rich people
segment today we're gonna pick on a
superstar yes
in the nba yeah
uh
bismack biambo yeah and i'm not an nba
guy obviously because i hesitated
pronouncing that don't tell me dave
ramsey doesn't prepare let's you should
just know that you should just know that
i sp yeah right
so
bismack apparently is one of these
gritty rich people because according to
this article on cnn uh he donated his
entire salary
from the nba
to build a hospital in his native
democratic republic of the congo
in africa
and honor his late father the phoenix
sunstar the 29 year old returned to the
nba in january signing a contract for
the duration of the season and he
donated the entire amount 1.3 million
dollars to build a hospital
in his home country
and he uh he donned the 18 jersey for
the sons in honor of his father's june
18th birthday his father passed away
and he's donating the entire amount
to be named after francis uh would con
consolidate his legacy whilst helping
those in need back home i told my agent
my salary for this year will be going to
the construction of a hospital back home
to give hope to the hopeless
at home and those individuals that
cannot take their family members
out biambo said greedy rich guy yeah oh
by the way dave that 1.3 million dollar
donation of a salary for the hospital is
in addition to the almost million
dollars worth of medical equipment that
his foundation uh sent over to the
democratic republic of congo in the
earliest of twenty twenty pretty rich
people do they usually double dip so
yeah so if you're gonna be greedy and
rich you should do it twice they have a
pattern of their greed yes this is
clearly a pattern out of control
generosity by these greedy rich people
it needs to stop you're giving bad name
to the greedy rich people when you're
generous like this that you need to stop
it yeah now here's what i'll also say
about how can that fit with the
narrative that's out there
well because here's what i mean well it
can't he's messing it up he can't he's
messing up the narrative but this is the
rare situation dave you know this
um i'm not very wealthy at all but i do
know a lot of wealthy people here's what
i know they don't normally talk about
their charity and their donation this is
a story because he's in the nba
but most rich people you don't even know
how much they're giving you don't even
know where their fingerprints are
because turns out these awful greedy
rich people don't need credit either
oh they weren't doing they weren't
taking a poll it wasn't optics yeah no
they just do it oh
kind of like covid yeah yeah yeah wasn't
about optics it wasn't about the way it
looked it's the way it actually is yeah
oh
that
i can't tell you how many rich people
that i've heard of and known that that
paid for supplies and private planes and
different countries all around the world
you never even see it on cnn but it's
happening it won't you you won't because
you won't find out about it and it
that'll be
reported i'm glad he reported this
because it exposed the greedy rich
people for what they really are yes and
i'm glad we have a news story i'm glad
cnn did their investigative journalism
and discovered that this guy is yet
another of those horrible successful
people
who are the best at their craft in the
world
and i chose to give the money away
and um build a hospital i think it's
just horrible it's just awful you know i
can't believe people really do stuff
like that yeah this new generation and
worse than that yeah he even talked
about it yeah and inspired other people
to be greedy rich people yeah it's just
horrible i can't believe it what a
horrible awful you know charles barkley
did the same thing we featured him on
the greedy rich people we featured dolly
parton on the gritty rich people
you know we should change it to the
famous shack was it shaq it was shaq it
wasn't barkley i'm sure barkley's a
greedy rich guy too yeah yeah he's
pretty much known for his you know his
donut i mean people
don't get me started on dolly parton
who's clearly one of the most evil
people to walk the face she's awful
she's awful i mean she just gives and
gives and gives and gives and gives and
gives all over tennessee but
particularly east tennessee her homeland
yeah i mean the level of generosity the
things she does for the workers at
dollywood the things she did with people
gatlinburg during the the fires the
money that was spent all all kids in
tennessee get free books to read by the
way and it's all dolly's fault because
she's a gritty rich lady and so they
just it's unbelievable what these people
do it's horrible it's awful they're
giving a bad name to rich people yeah
it's messing up the messing up the lefty
narrative there it is see that narrative
exists folks because it's all about
politics and the tax rate so if we can
make the rich people look evil
then we can tax them more for government
programs there's the rest of the story
if you want to simplify how it works
pretty simple because government good
rich people bad well yes the government
knows what to do with that works why
trust really they're more efficient yeah
they're more efficient at losing the
money yeah then the actual people who by
the way created an unbelievable product
or made millions and by the way hired
thousands and paid them tens of millions
of dollars but the government can do
better than the actual successful rich
people world if you were really
generous you would pay a higher tax bill
and let uncle sam figure out how to
distribute because he's because he's
he's um
wiser uncle sam is wise and efficient
yeah yeah yeah
is the sarcasm font on
i hope we made it obvious that uh we're
being sarcastic for new listeners don't
don't the subtitles are not in the
sarcasm we're in trouble now yeah you
know we just lost all of our entire
tribe but yeah but this is really
turning into something far more serious
dave and it's class warfare and it's a
dangerous thing you know because you
know it's worse it's worse than class
warfare it's it's a war on success yeah
because the upper class in the united
states did not become that way by
aristocracy or by inheritance that's
correct they earned it that's right and
they earned it through successful living
and saving and
serving
and
[Music]
this guy earned it well no basketball
player well then don't go to an nba game
and pay them if you don't believe that
but if you're going to go over there and
pay the ticket price then shut up about
what they get paid because you paid it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
foreign
well we know time's important it's even
more precious than money or shiny toys
or winning certificates at work and like
spending money from an account when you
don't know how much is in it we never
know how much time we really have so if
you could do one thing
that would make the time you have
even more worthwhile you'd do it
wouldn't you of course you would we get
that and we want you to have everything
you need to be well
and that's why we're partnering with
betterhelp to give you a month of free
one-on-one weekly therapy when you
pre-order a copy of dr john dolone's new
book own your past
change your future who does that well i
better help and ramsay that's who you're
never too old or too young to improve
your health and make your relationship
stronger your free month of one-on-one
therapy
that is weekly will give you the tools
you need to change your future because
you'll get matched up with a therapist
based on your specific needs it's
life-changing combo the new book own
your past change your future comes out
next week it'll make you laugh it'll
make you cry it did me it will challenge
you it did me and when you take the
first steps the dr deloney outlines to
take advantage of your free therapy
you'll also be transformed it's amazing
all of this for 20 bucks if you
pre-order now the book is next tuesday a
week from tuesday
it's here and all the special deals and
the free e-book and the free audio book
and the better help therapy sessions all
go away
if you don't pre-order the book for
twenty dollars it's all included for
twenty dollars at ramsey solutions.com
own your past change your future the
book will change your life it's
incredible i'm so excited about it the
pre-sales are off the chain this guy is
quite hot his show is exploding and he
it's absolutely doing absolutely amazing
job we're so
so proud of him
and with two phds that means he's got
two more than you and me put together oh
yeah oh yeah absolutely i can't even
spell phd we're still working on that i
got a phd in d-umb all right there we go
hey james is in philadelphia hey james
what's up
hey dave how's everything going better
than i deserve how can i help
good gun so dave i'm a current third
year podiatric medical student my wife
and i we're currently debt free
and we have enough money to save for or
we have enough money saved that we can
pay for the rest of my tuition
but now with the current
politics and the environment that's
going on with the student loans and
what's going on with the federal
government we're now considering taking
out a loan for almost 50k student loan
and then using that money to invest
especially since there's zero interest
on federal student loans
we would do that with the option to pay
that right away off once the interest
starts to accrue
and then once student debt forgiveness
is officially off the table do you think
this is a smart decision in your eyes
so you're doing this in the hope that
you don't have to repay it
not necessarily
more or less we would invest it while
there is zero percent interest accruing
but if the off chance that student debt
does get forgiven we would basically
just
i mean save our back then because we
would be
a little bit disappointed if student
loans were forgiven when we pit out of
pocket all this time
okay
um
well couple of breakdowns in that
where you and i are not aligned and um
i'll walk through those with you because
you called and asked us okay
so the first thing is is um i i'm not
aligned that we
take out student loans with the hope
that they are forgiven uh because to me
that's like taking money you weren't
supposed to take because you didn't need
it and it's kind of like i don't know
that that feels like stealing to me okay
i'll just say it out loud and um the
second thing is
borrowing money to invest
at a greater interest rate than the
money is costing you
has not proven to be something we found
in the data that causes people to become
wealthy
so borrowing money to invest
is not the normative way
it's statistically unusual
as a way to build wealth what i mean is
when we studied 10
167 millionaires the number of
millionaires that borrowed money to
invest
called arbitrage or playing margin
anytime you're borrowing money to invest
you can borrow money to buy real estate
uh you're borrowing money to invest
hoping that the investment is going to
create a greater rate of return
than the money cost you when you borrow
it the number of people that built
wealth doing that was way less than five
percent
meaning that 96 97 percent of the
millionaires we interviewed did not use
this process to become millionaires
now if i told you as a procedure in
medical school that you had a 97 failure
rate you would avoid that procedure
oh yeah definitely because the data
tells you that the facts tell you that
this methodology
is not successful but three or four
percent of the time
um and so you would avoid that
methodology and so i'm gonna tell you
not to borrow money and so what i'm
saying is what sounds smart on the
surface has not proven out to be the
typical way people build wealth
because what you're leaving out of the
equation is the risk situation and
you're adding stress you're adding
risk anytime you borrow money you add
risk the more money you borrow the more
risk you have
and that enters into the factor it
enters into relationships it enters into
mental wellness it enters into the
stress across the back of your neck
it enters into the stress around your
heart um
it enters into the job you take because
you're in debt or not in debt i
understand you have the money in the
bank to pay it off so your level of risk
is relatively low compared to someone
that's playing you know borrowing the
money and going to vegas and has a
problem right i understand you're not
doing that i get that and and so i see
the logic and and how you got there but
um i'm just telling you the procedure
that you're using is not used
normatively by people who get the result
that you're looking for i would also say
that the logic is based on a hope and a
wish and i think it's just simply that
when i was growing up dave you'll
remember i'm 47 so all the 40-somethings
will remember this crazy
giant chicken named foghorn legore and
he used to terrorize the bulldog in in
that cartoon he would put a stake on the
end of a fishing pole and he'd hold it
out in front of that bulldog and make
that bulldog just chase that steak and
chase that state he didn't know huh he
didn't know that he's been canceled oh
he has yeah the bulldog union oh is that
right i didn't know this
i thought you were serious for a second
i was like did i really miss that
because anything's possible he just
killed my metaphor here's the deal
biden and the democrats are dangling
this policy out there yeah and i'm just
going to tell you this isn't a political
statement some of you will call it that
you can get over it later but i'm
telling you
that they are dangling that as a
possibility to garner votes
they have been in power before
they power right now they are done
what have they done you know and they've
got everything they got congress they
got the senate they got they're not
going to do it here's why until until
october they got all three yeah if you
want to pass a law right now is the time
to pass it but they never have and they
never will here's why you go do the
research yourself folks that's big money
sallie mae freddie it is big money for
the federal government it has been since
they started the student loan program
way back in the late 50s early 60s and
replaced the pell grant this is a big
money play for the government they're
not going to forgive student loans ever
and i just think that if that wasn't a
potential you know kind of a stake out
there dangling in front of people
then they wouldn't be thinking about
this and i just got to tell you i don't
mean to be the bearer of bad news
they're not going to do it they've had
chances before this is not a new idea
this is not a new concept this is
recycled political jargon and i wouldn't
trust it for a second yeah well even if
they do
it's still not right to your even if
they do i agree with that i agree i'm
borrowing money
the government gives it uh you know it's
like saying that's like
saying i'm unemployed when i'm not yeah
so that i get unemployment or like
saying
i'm broke so i get my welfare check even
though i'm making money on the table
all of those are theft
all of those are morally wrong
and
so i wouldn't do it for those reasons
but thank you for the call and
appreciate the discussion it's very very
good
i'll add one thing to this whole
discussion because it sounds like we're
somehow kind of uh self-righteous nems
or something but again data okay the guy
who wrote uh millionaire next door tom
stanley was a friend of mine before he
passed away wrote the book in 1992 he
wrote a follow-up book later of on deca
millionaires people that had 10 million
dollars or more he studied 38
characteristics he was a statistician
that was his background a marketing guy
and he studied 38 characteristics of the
people that became deca millionaires the
most correlated
of the different variables married
race profession whatever
character qualities the most correlated
of all the 38 in all the deca
millionaires number one indicator you're
going to be a deck of millionaire was
outlandish fanatical levels of
integrity don't get that one very often
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today cameron's in grand rapids
michigan hi cameron welcome to the
ramsey show
hi how are you guys doing today great
man what's up
uh so i have a question i have a uh a
job opportunity
that's gonna help me make uh about
double what i make right now
uh but it's a traveling job what are you
making you have to buy
uh about 55. okay so you make 110 if you
travel
yep it's a traveling job so i would be
looking to buy a rv
uh and i don't have all the money to buy
it
so i'd have to get a loan
why do you have to have an rv
uh to stay in while i'm there why don't
you just run a hotel
uh
i wanted to bring my my dogs with me my
girlfriend
okay
was that a statement or a question
sounded like a statement uh or is there
a question in there
no a statement yeah i'd like to bring my
dogs my girlfriend with me
okay
again you just made a statement so
that's you it's your life you can do
whatever you want
but going on i was just wondering if it
was a good uh a good idea to take the
new
job and make the extra money it is but
it's not a good idea
buying rv on debt yeah exactly
okay yes you know how fast cars go down
in value
rvs are worse
right they're a black hole for money
you want to know how to you know how to
have a small fortune start with a large
fortune and buy rvs
[Laughter]
yeah it's going to end up looking like
that thing on christmas vacation anyway
don't be cousin eddie no um
[Laughter]
so yeah i i think you probably do this
and you pay cash for
a nice used rv
after you've been on the road six months
in uh temporary housing
now are you in in one location at a time
or are you in different locations every
week or
yeah it'd be like a six-month commitment
to one place
and then uh i'd move on from there oh
okay so you could like rent a property
that allowed
dogs yeah i could do that as well i
don't think about that the the places
are super rural so i didn't know if
there were going to be any there but i
can check pretty pretty likely they'll
allow dogs in yeah and there's somebody
renting something in the rural areas too
and so you don't even have to
necessarily do hotel you might find a
great room over a garage you know i mean
there's a lot of ways to do this and
bank most of this new money what's your
girlfriend do for a living
uh she's a manager a
job grocery store
so she's gonna do that remote
uh no she'd come with me and then she'd
do school
full time
go to school
yeah oh okay
all right
and so she's not gonna be making any
money
uh most likely no okay
all right
um
i i think for the first uh year to two
years of this experiment i would rent a
home in each location
and make sure that this is a stick if
you're gonna keep doing this for a five
or ten year period the rv might make
sense
otherwise the
the loss and value of the rv is going to
make you wish you had paid rent
if you add up how much the rv's going
down in value it will be the equivalent
of renting a fairly nice place depending
on how nice an rv you buy of course but
the nicer rv you would buy the more the
nicer rental property you would compare
it to
and so um
you know they just they just don't do
well on values
and so i'm afraid you're gonna get stuck
and here's what's happened uh you got
this job offer and now you've
romanticized the traveling part of it in
your head
um versus the actual work part of it
and so the the math on taking the job
and doubling your income that all works
but then you then you went off the
reservation over here because you're
trying to get fun and fritzy and we're
going to turn this into an adventure
and uh
no you're just going to turn it into
cousin eddie don't do it um no i would i
would i would rent a house if i were in
your shoes and i woke up i'd probably go
on the adventure but i'd rent the house
and i would um
if i'm gonna keep doing this long term i
would buy a used
rv with cash that i save up because i
make twice as much as i used to make i
got a question for you dave and i this
is not a suggestion i don't want anybody
to think i'm making the suggestion but i
am curious what do you think about the
tiny house
that you can pull on wheels i just
haven't done any research i understand
the rv's devalue what do you think about
the tiny house on wheels
no there's no resale value right yeah
but it's a whole lot less money yeah but
it's no resale value again it's
consumption so i i would just go with
something i agree if you don't
have to own something
in order to make this happen let's not
own something i agree because it could
be a temporary decision that way yeah
and it increases the quality of the
adventure yep not venture adventure
minnesota
is on the line and that's lee calling hi
lee how are you
hi thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's up
um we were wondering my husband and i um
your thoughts on potentially buying a
house right now
we have started the process about two
years ago to build a house um we have
the land
but with the
materials costs and everything kind of
going a little haywire over the past
couple years we're thinking we might not
be building as soon as we would have
liked um we had heard about house that's
coming up for sale
in a couple days um and wondering your
guys's thoughts like is it still worth
it to potentially buy a house if we hope
to sell it and build in the next like
five to six years yes
okay
okay
let's let's think about this for a
second
think about this for a second how old
are you guys
um 30. okay
so can you remember when you're 25
yeah remember what houses have done
since you were 25 until you were 30.
increasing value would have been a good
move wouldn't it
yeah
yep
that's that's how i did that
okay
so even though like it's kind of going
haywire right now that you don't
anticipate it i have no idea i mean
there's no no one knows what's going to
happen for sure
but uh i am investing in real estate as
we speak
i believe in real estate i i don't it
may it may it may have a little bit of a
cycle it may turn back down but long
term it'll turn up and you'll be fine
and it would be a very unusual five to
seven year period of time that the house
didn't go up in value
enough that you make money on it when
you resell it even after expenses
and be a very unusual don't have to be
quite hot for this to work it just has
to be a normal market and if you did it
in the last five years you would have
participated in one of the hottest real
estate markets in history
so it would have been highly unusual in
the last five years that you didn't make
money but um you can't count on that as
being the future but if you count on
just a normal real estate rhythm that's
a long enough time horizon that you're
going to be just fine
and i i'm kind of with you i like the
idea of waiting a little while and
letting because i do think the building
materials and the labor force is going
to
come back down to normal i think it's
out of control but that's a supply
demand thing where housing prices also
supply demand thing but there's
a little likelihood it's going to catch
up as much as the building materials
catch up
so we get past the coveted dip
on the lumber yards not having any
lumber and then all of a sudden they had
lumber again and it was double and it
takes a little while for that to
smooth out that wrinkle in the economy
to smooth out and that's what's caused
some of our inflation
is the results of the factories being
shut down during quarantine therefore
creating a shortage and anytime there's
a shortage you see price increase
that's pretty simple
and pretty simple it's seventh grade
econ okay so good question appreciate
you calling in open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five i'll tell you what i
did not seek in
i had no clue
that today
two years
it's basically two years since the peak
of covid right now
the quarantines all started about two
years ago right now
um and that two years later we'd still
be seeing economic effects from this
yeah
um i don't think many people did i
honestly
thought it was going to be a very
short-lived thing
uh and the the results the economic
impact of the quarantines
um
the flattening of the curve
uh the economic suppression by
government
uh the the
world that a lot of people are living in
that is not a good world right now is a
result of that still
two years later you can't blame all that
on biden that was on a quarantine that
did that that's right this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life here on
the ramsay show calvin's with us in
raleigh north carolina hi calvin how are
you
hi dave i'm very honored and uh
extremely grateful to be speaking with
you today and
your ministry has
literally changed my life so thank you
for that well thank you we're honored
thank you
my question today is i need advice on a
plan so um
i want to i'm calling it semi-retire
but
i'm i'm not passionate about a 30-year
career that i
am wanting to end and what my question
is should i make a career change at my
age
that will probably reduce my income
dramatically and it may even go to zero
while i'm contracting a house and um
what i want to do is be a builder owner
sorry yeah build my own house and also i
want to begin a um
a process of becoming a financial coach
so
i i like to give you a little bit of
background i've been with the same
company 30 years and as i said
i'm not very passionate about it anymore
i i feel like all i'm doing is um
showing up and
um making a large corporation a lot of
money which you know i'm very grateful
for the 30 years that they've given to
me but i'm not passionate about doing it
anymore what do you guys really like to
help
i'm sorry what do you make
um as far as salary or what's your
income um
200
okay
and how old are you
i'm 55. okay and what's your net worth
um
probably
3.6 million okay
and is a lot of that invested where you
can live off of the income that 3.6
million creates
so
some of it i probably could
about
about um
1.1 million
is in 401ks that obviously can't live
off um for my age right um
but another million is
um
well another one
yeah 1 million probably to 1.4 million
is in either cash or um
or investment accounts
and another factor is my wife um
will still be working while i do this
and she makes approximately 130.
okay and your goal is to build a house
for yourself
correct okay so that's kind of an
independent variable you're going to do
that either way
um well it's either that or stay
employed and let a contractor build the
house for me oh so you would be the
general contractor on the house
yes sir that's right okay but the
business that you want to start up for
the remainder of your income is you want
to be a financial coach
yes and i
and i'm not even sure i want to charge
for that um i i i've listened to your
webinar and i want to probably sign up
for your master financial coach
curriculum
um but i'm not sure if i'm ready to
charge people for that or
um just do that as you know a free thing
for people who need assistance what do
you do now the position what kind of
work that you've been doing for 30 years
i manage business systems
for a large corporation okay
okay
you've earned the right to do whatever
you want 3.6 million you can do whatever
you want to do
okay
so there's there's no
um downside so what you're trading out
for is you're walking away from 200k
for potentially zero income
um right and that's the only disturbing
part of it just because it sounds like a
bad use of you
not because you need the money
um and i wouldn't tell you to stay in
the 200k long term but i might tell you
to stay in it another year and get the
business to get the coaching business up
and running because i think you'll feel
better about you
if you're at least earning a you know
half of what you used to earn
and you get moving again and because
you're just a guy that moves things
around i mean you're not
you know no boss grows on you dude
you've been moving stuff around for a
long long time and you just kind of hit
the wall emotionally on this one gig
but i i think you'll feel better about
you if this doesn't go to zero i think
that might create some kind of a
backlash inside your emotions it
wouldn't mind if i went to zero
what are you yeah why why are you so uh
what's the emotional pull to be a
financial coach what's that desired
result
in your words
when you coach people what's that
desired result when you're done coaching
somebody financially what do you want to
see people do
to put people in a position
where
money is not
the sole focus so that they can focus
their lives on
something better than just money where
you are you
yes
right right where
i mean 20 years ago i listened to your
show and
i
i'm a nerd so i put it in a spreadsheet
just the debt snowball and honestly i
didn't even follow the baby steps but
i i passed it by a friend of mine and he
said that's not real life that will
never happen
and
and
in five years i was out of debt and from
there i've just kept going so i want
other people to feel
the freedom of that so calvin here's why
i asked those two quick questions i i
agree with what dave is saying i i don't
know that you have to have this
narrative in your mind that it's zero
and it's just ministry or it's just
personal um with the money you all make
and the discipline you have if you you
know if you want to step away from this
job where you've where the soul has been
sucked out of you it's just there's no
juice for you and i think that's kind of
creating a little bit of confusion uh if
you want to go build the house you know
however long it's going to take to build
the house you got the cash and all that
maybe that be a little bit of a break
but i would really challenge you to look
not just at financial coaching but even
like the men and women we call smart
vester pros where you get into true
retirement investment advice as well
where you can have tremendous impact
there but also make a really good living
because at your age i think there's just
so much more impact there but i would
encourage you to not just see well
for 30 years i've given so much to this
company and as it stands right now i
just don't feel like i i've got the
juice i get that but that doesn't mean
we swing all the way over here
uh and and not make any money at all or
more importantly it's not about money
for you i think it's contribution which
is what i talk about all the time uh on
the ken coleman show and what we do here
at ramsey solutions it relates to work
you know work is a contribution to make
the world a better place and we can hear
that in you and i just think there's
more options here amen
well done sir proud of you good work
sharon's in auburn alabama hi sharon
what's up
hey how you doing thanks for taking my
call sure i'm a school i'm a school
teacher in elementary school and uh
um was planning on retiring in three
years but
a little thing happened my husband
decided he didn't want to be married
anymore so
i'm trying to make sure that
i'm gonna be on the right track
financially
i don't have any debt
i do have emergency funds
set up and i have
60 000
put in a account for
putting down a house
which is not enough in auburn
but my
question is i'm trying to decide
should i be putting more money
in my retirement
and not you know just keep renting
or should all my extra cash go
toward down payment for a house i'd put
it as a down payment on the house and
put it on as short a term as you can 15
years maybe 10 years if you can
because i want to get it paid i want to
get it paid off as quick as i can
but um and use the 60 000 which probably
came from the sale of the marital house
didn't it
uh yes yeah yeah and so yeah i would use
that as your down payment on the next
house buy something conservative and get
it paid off as soon as you can while
you're funding retirement
and that's what we call baby steps four
five and six you're putting 15 of your
income away for retirement and any extra
money you can find beyond that you're
paying on the house and get the house
paid off i'd love for you to have a paid
for house and a juicy nest egg when you
get to those retired retirement years
that sets you up for a lot of stability
in a quality quality retirement
but for sure you want to be in the real
estate business no question about that
because rents aren't going anywhere but
up
and you don't want to be on that cycle
long term not a good long term cycle
good question thank you for joining us
ken coleman good hour this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your
relationships your mental health your
job your career and your money overall
your life right here on the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five brian is in california hey brian
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going thank you for
taking my call my pleasure sir how can i
help
yeah um so i'm just gonna read out this
thing that i wrote here it says
i'm debt free i have an emergency fund i
have a business emergency fund as well
and i'm on baby step 3b
and i just want to know if i made the
right decision i've worked for seven
years in the construct in the
construction industry since the age of
18 i am now 25
making really good money
in my own business and i feel bad like i
let my ex-employer down
did i make a good decision leaving my
old company
my family make me feel bad like i charge
too much i have many clients that are
happy to pay my rate
and honestly i charge what an average
professional handyman charges in my area
so what did you used to make
um
i made thirty dollars an hour
and then what do you well okay i'm gonna
show what's that equate to a year
like uh 55 000 okay so you're making 60
grand a year and what do you make now
now like 120.
i'm confused where the mistake might be
yeah it's just
um my old company has called me earlier
today
and they want a decision and they want
to know if i'm going to come back
because initially i told them i was
going to take a break no i don't have
brandon
all right am i missing something coleman
i what i'd well i don't know why your
family's making you feel badly about
leaving this company when you've doubled
over you've doubled your salary and
you're working for yourself i mean my
goodness i just don't understand i'm not
sure what's missing either but you don't
need to feel guilty or bad i don't know
if they're worried about stability but
there's this myth sometimes
with our friends and family members who
don't have an entrepreneurial spirit
maybe they've never worked for a true
entrepreneur maybe they've never done it
themselves and so they think government
jobs or well if you work for a bigger
company it's more stable the fact of the
matter is is that you are more stable
working for you with the skill sets that
you have because i gotta tell you
something during the pandemic what we
saw are folks like you were booming with
their businesses and their work so i
don't know what's missing either but you
need to stay working for yourself based
on what i've heard
so the only reason you would go back to
work for the other company is because
your relatives say you charge too much
and it's evil that you've become wealthy
doing this at 25 years old or or you
would go back to work there because
somehow you have some kind of misguided
loyalty to a company that used to pay
you less than half of what you make now
yeah it's more the other last part you
know i feel like
yeah okay
no
there's never been anyone that worked at
ramsey that left here and made double
that i suggested they should come back
for half
never okay never have i suggested that
because i actually like the people that
work here and if they can make double
somewhere else i would like that for
them
generally speaking these days that's not
possible because we peso dadgum much now
but in the old days when we were getting
started we didn't pay a lot and people
would leave and go make more money and i
just had to help them leave and go with
i love you and go make more money that's
awesome go do it
but i don't have to do that these days
thank god but the um yeah because but
but you need to keep doing what you're
doing
so uh brian i had a relative several
years ago that loved me deeply
and she was a very very sweet little
lady
and her husband had worked in corporate
america at the same job for 38 years
and she was so thankful that he had this
steady job
and every time i would see her
she would ask me when i was going to get
a real job
the last time she asked me that in that
calendar year i made more in that one
year than her husband made in his entire
working lifetime
but she was still waiting on me to get a
real job
yeah i hear you and so it was not
because she was bad she actually loved
me and she was worried about me
because she was worried it was unstable
and that being self-employed is unstable
and what you find out when you're
self-employed like you are especially
with when you're a handyman and you're
probably a one or a two-man show you
find out that you are actually the
secret sauce at the end of the day at
the end of the day you are what uh
really you can count on and by the way
it was that way all along
just that way all along
when that guy worked for corporate
america that was my relative who was a
sweet man he was a nice man i'm not
belittling him at all but it was just
the mathematics were humorous
of her point of me getting a real job
and she just desired security
uh to the point that she misjudged where
security comes from and security comes
from your ability to get up leave the
cave and kill something and drag it home
and you have proven your ability to do
that young man i'm very proud of you you
should keep doing what you're doing
yeah well done thank you
so much dave thank you so much thank you
god bless you
wow
i talked to a handyman the other day you
made 300 last year oh yeah this is
stinking because you can't get nobody to
show up if you just show up you can
charge about anything you want to charge
yeah it's pretty amazing it's a premium
service and you know just that young man
right there wouldn't you love to have
him in your house and stuff oh i would
definitely pay him sweet spirit
and let's let's just let's just belabor
this point about the size of a company
equating to stability
we've all seen large companies
completely evaporate or lay off people
by the thousands okay i mean peloton did
it recently they were the hottest uh one
of the hottest consumer products and
during the pandemic until they weren't
until they weren't remember enron go
look that story up a public company so
you know this idea that well i'm gonna
put my fortune in somebody else's hands
and that's stable well that's just a
bunch of garbage especially when you
work for yourself you got sound
financial principles here's the thing
you always
work for yourself when you work for a
company
you just have one client that's right
you got one customer yeah that's it
and when you work for yourself and you
have a bunch of customers it's no
different
you know and so i've got millions of
customers
and uh but when you work for a company
and you're you know james has one
customer as far as i know yeah
we're his only customer ramsey solutions
and that's not a bad thing that's not
the end of the world but this idea that
somehow that you're not self-employed at
the end of the day your responsibility
your life is your responsibility and
when you acquit when you turn that
responsibility over to someone else when
you
dispatch it to someone else in the name
of security and you say okay i'm no
longer have to worry about that because
that company's going to worry about it
you just sacrificed something so we tell
our people around here they're all
self-employed we say it all the time
it's one of our 14 core values you're
self-employed you're self-employed
you're self-employed act like you're
self-employed act like you own this
place act like when you see a piece of
paper on the ground pick it up like you
own the place
be responsible act like you're
self-employed act like you're
self-employed
and even if you're not technically
you'll always prosper with that
mentality
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at ramsay we're big fans of those of you
who serve
by the way that's almost all of you but
really those of you that serve in the
military we love you those of you that
serve in the classroom teachers we're
big fans of teachers here and all year
long you've been grinding it out to make
sure your students are actually learning
despite all the distractions that
they're dealing with right now and you
work so dad blame hard
and you care even more
it's teachers like you who have taught
our foundations and personal finance
curriculum and have changed the lives of
over 5
million students have now gone through
this in high school
april is national financial literacy
month and we're celebrating teachers
with our teacher appreciation giveaway
even teachers that have not even
taught the class yet our class they just
teach if you're just a teacher we just
love teachers we love just teachers
sponsored this is a giveaway sponsored
by borrowed future it's our hit
documentary about the dark side of the
student loan industry a teacher can
enter to win no purchase necessary today
we're going to be giving away five
thousand dollars cash to two lucky
teachers and three teachers will each
win one thousand dollars cash and even
more
don't miss out teachers go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher if you know a teacher that you
love uh be sure you just tell them to go
to ramseysolutions.com
teacher and uh get signed up because hey
you might win 5 000 bucks somebody does
every time we do this there's going to
be two of them this time and financial
literacy month our way of celebrating
teachers if you haven't read the blog we
posted uh that i posted
on my various social media channels i
didn't do the posting i wrote the blog
um because i don't even know how to do
the posting uh on
instagram and what is it facebook and
those other things is on there so you
can find it just me uh celebrating all
the old
school teachers i love old teachers
and some of you are young teachers but
you've got those old teacher values and
that's the ones that that we love they
were the ones that were tough on us and
put up with us and loved us and um we
all every one of us credit our success
to some of those old type old school
type teachers
and uh so check it out open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our question of the day comes from
blinds.com we have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee they do if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds free and you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsay to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from eric in south dakota
is it advisable to enroll in a
certification course
during baby step 2 i'm interested in a
20-hour course which cost 500
this certification could improve my
salary expectations by more than five
thousand dollars a year as well as
improving my resume if i were to shop
the market my company would reimburse me
for the course upon completion without
any explicit agreement to remain there
for a specific period of time i would
just need the initial cash on hand i
know gazelle intensity means rice and
beans and beans and rice so i wanted to
get your thoughts on this scenario
well uh in this situation eric this just
seems like all upside and you're going
to get reimbursed and so i was 20 hours
yeah do it 20 hours after this
no-brainer 20 months we'll talk about it
yeah we we teach cash you have to cash
flow things during the baby steps and
and so this is just another one of those
things so i'd do whatever i had to do
scrape sell whatever i'd come up with
the cash change the budget a little bit
and this is a very temporary uh
expenditure and bust through it yeah
crush it yeah don't don't hang around
with this thing for two years and talk
about it bust through it one month be
done in a month and get your money right
back
and then it's a no no harm no foul right
that's right and then you've got an
increased income and or the potential
for an increased income i would do this
as many times as you can do it
this kind of thing with certifications
proves that what we tell young people
all the time
is the best possible investment you can
make is in you
if it's a wise investment now what he's
done there is he has
said this is what it costs and this is
what he goes back so the net result for
him is it costs zero
at the end of the day that's right and
he increases his income potential by
five thousand dollars a year that's kind
of a no-brainer yeah it's absolutely do
it you know and here's the thing we're
seeing today in this marketplace more
and more opportunities to what they're
called upskill
and and but be smart about it you know
there's a lot anytime you see you know a
marketplace like this where it's easier
to get up skilled you're also going to
see frauds and so my only caution would
be do your homework make sure there's
it's a reputable opportunity and that
you can as davis said roi that get a
return on that investment well all
education is that i had this long
discussion with our friend mike rowe on
his podcast the other day posted uh we
ended up talking an hour because we're
just so much alike but all we were
talking about is he he really is upset
about this idea that we consider
education and investment
no i'm not um he said but but he's
saying that that's the con
sure and it is it is a part of the con
yes but it's not but it is it can be can
be
and what i said is is
the part of the con is is that it's
always a good investment it is an
investment
but is it a bad one or a good one now if
you go spend 200 000 to get a degree in
left-handed puppetry then that's a bad
investment but if you go spend 500 bucks
and you get a degree you up one of your
certs then you got a 5 000 return on
that and they give you your money back
too then that's an infinite return then
this is a good investment and so
knowledge is always an investment it's
either a good investment or a bad
investment does it pay you more than it
costs you would be the good investment
type uh but if all you learn how to do
is um you know
you know you've got seven degrees in
philosophy and so you're a barista then
that's a problem yeah and you're going
to struggle with that and you're not
going to get the return on investment
not mad at you barista philosophy
students but just like just saying uh
you don't want to spend 200 000 for the
opportunity to draw someone else's
coffee not a plan
um and so
and that's not poking fun it's poking
fun at not the individuals it's the
system and how screwed up it is that we
actually told people that that was a
good idea yeah
and that's what the whole movie uh the
documentary that we did has been so
popular uh by the way thank you guys for
all of the things we found out this
morning won an award yeah so pretty cool
yeah and um who knew yeah hard future up
for a webby you know what they call it a
webby so is that what that's called
that's what they call it okay well you
got awards for everything one thing i
want to add to this really quick there's
also on the on the edge of this
marketing pitch that dave was just
talking about is also this idea that if
i get the degree that all i have to do
is largely send out the resumes and
people are going to clamor for me and
that is not true i just recently uh
spoke
on the campus of vanderbilt uh just last
week doctoral students and the number
one question for me was ken
how do i actually get the gig i want so
don't forget that even with the
doctorate or the the masters
you are now going to have to compete you
still got it training camp's over just a
tool on your belt you got to win the
game you got to win you got to beat the
competition and that's what uh we're
seeing a trend now people are staying in
degrees well if i get this degree well i
didn't get a job now i got to get
another degree and
it can be valuable but remember even if
you need it
you're still going to have to compete it
just occurred to me that what we told
the whole generation was that you're in
willy wonka's chocolate factory and if
you get the golden ticket that's correct
you get a free ride that's what people
think i just sit back it's not it's not
willy wonka's golden ticket it's simply
a conversation piece
and the knowledge that you got on the
way to getting your degree
which bro brought up an interesting
point in that uh podcast he said that we
use the word degree every else
everywhere else we use the word degree
it means a small increment
oh that's a great statement like a
degree on a thermometer if you change
the degree from 72 to 73 degrees no one
notices you got a degree yeah no one
noticed it's a very interesting point
and we act like it's a promise of a
better future well
it is always good to add knowledge oh
yeah but useful knowledge is called
wisdom yeah but that pro that better
future has everything to do with what
you do with knowledge it's the better it
is
is it useful
and useful knowledge and the secret
sauce to success we told people was a
degree and it's not the secret sauce to
success is you that's correct you yeah
persistence integrity
integrity continually persistence
continual personal growth integrity
persistence
hustle
grind
humility you're not the answer to the
equation
you're just the answer to your equation
no one really cares what you think
because you've done nothing yet go do
something and then have an opinion
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
kid coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five sydney is
with us and sydney is in phoenix arizona
says on my screen you're debt-free
congratulations
thank you so much way to go kiddo how
much you pay off
i paid off 65 038 months good for you
way to go and making what kind of range
of income during that three years in two
months uh in the three years i started
at 35 000 and i doubled my income during
that time to 70.
yes wow what do you do for a living
yeah i'm a reporter a sports reporter
with usa today um i started at a local
paper and then worked my way up um to
where i'm at currently right now
and that all started with my debt
debt-free journey three years ago when i
was looking at the numbers trying to
move into my own place and realized that
i could not afford it or much of
anything
okay so the debt-free journey says i
need to make more money so you got after
it
yes i instantly started applying for new
jobs and then uh land with the company
that i am right now and then have been
there ever since so way to go
yeah this journey has been a blessing in
more ways than i can count i'm so proud
of you what was the uh uh
how old are you
i am 27 years old what was the debt what
kind of debt was the 65 000
um so most of it was student loans so 46
000 with student loans i also before the
debt free
journey i was leasing a car so i turned
that back in got a used car paid that
off uh student loans and then some
medical bills as well but majority of it
was student loans you rock kiddo what
kind of used car did you get
i got a toyota or a nissan a nissan
sentra all right nice car
yeah i love it yeah good for you how's
it feel to be free at 27
it feels it feels great at first it did
feel a little surreal just because i've
been working towards this goal for so
long
and you know in the beginning it just
seems so
unattainable or or borderline impossible
but just working the steps every day
you know of course it was hard but
really just staying plugged in and
reaching that goal just feels literally
like such a huge relief such a huge
weight off of my shoulders and i feel
like it just couldn't have come at a
more perfect time so i'm really really
excited and super grateful
yeah way to go
way to go i'm proud of you so fun yeah
uh sydney i've got to ask you as a
sports reporter you cover a lot of great
athletes
what is the uh parallel the metaphor
through the debt-free journey that also
applies to champions in sport that
you've noticed during your own journey
uh so right now i live in phoenix so
covering a lot of the phoenix suns who
are doing really well but i'm originally
from california so i will relate it to
kobe bryant when he talks about that
mamba mentality and even on the
debt-free journey how you face vegan
bell intent so just every day waking up
knowing that
this day even you know i worked two jobs
during the whole time and you know my
days started around five in the morning
um so just getting up every day even if
i was tired or or didn't necessarily
feel like it just knowing that
this day was for something greater and
just having that mentality to uh just
continue to go after it
um so i would definitely say that it
took a little bit of mamba mentality to
get where i am right now at an
additional additional to being gazelle
intent
way to go good for you you're amazing
yeah you are a rock star man i'm so
proud of you very very very well done
who are your biggest cheerleaders
um i would say i had the cheerleaders
with my friends and family but i do want
to give a special shout out to
my two friends elena and maurice they
were the ones who actually lent me your
book total money makeover and got me on
this journey
and we ended up doing it together so it
was really
really such a blessing just to have
someone my age doing the same journey on
it you know when you see a lot of people
really living their life or or not
making these sacrifices that that we are
it was cool to have that support system
on the same journey we ended up being
debt-free within a couple weeks from
each other um and you will actually be
able to meet them soon they are coming
to see you and do their own debt free
screams so
a lot of them
yeah they were a really big help during
this time what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is um i would
just say just first setting that goal
when i set michael like i said it just
seems so impossible but once you set
that goal once you really sit down with
the numbers and and just work the baby
steps
it's possible so i would definitely say
trust the process
um that was the most important thing
just knowing that like what you're
saying is true and you'll get there it
just takes time and dedication
and patience so
definitely trust the process is what i
would tell everybody out there um even
if you think that you can't do it just
fake it till you make it and before you
know it you'll be that free
well push through even if you don't know
if you're going to make it that's
different exactly
you're an amazing young woman i'm so
proud of you very very very well done
yeah we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth how you can
too that's the next chapter in your
story you'll be a millionaire before you
know it at this rate well done well done
well done
also another copy of total money
makeover that way you can give it away
and stir up a ruckus for somebody else
so good stuff good stuff all right it's
sydney in phoenix arizona 27 years old
making uh paid off 65 000 in 38 months
making 35 to 70. doubled her income
while she was doing it count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
yes
very cool sharp young woman
twice she said in that call that uh i
trusted the process you hear that for a
lot of athletes these days of course
she's obviously a sports journalist but
you hear that a lot of athletes across
all of walks of sport and it's it is a
beautiful way to describe the clear path
which are the baby steps this is a
process that works time in and time out
she said trust the process trust the
baby steps it is a process it is a
process and when you do it it works
kelly's in phoenix hi kelly welcome to
the ramsay show
hi there i'm so grateful to be on
blessings to you both for all that you
do and everything you put your hands to
for fighting so hard to help people
thank you um live free thank you so
i'm considering buying an agency so um
i have my career for 21 years 22 years
and
i'm 51 years old
so i'm considering
um i'm gonna have to look at what it's
going to look like when i just i'm just
way too tired to be
in my career and
so i was looking to buy a company
and i
they're going to be giving me all the
information i need but the question i
really have because there's not
something i've done before so i need to
figure out how to look for what the roi
is how much to offer them
i don't know what type of agency
i'm sorry what was that question what
type of agency
um it's an interpreting agency okay all
right the language language agency
gotcha okay cool
um
well a good rule of thumb is this
uh four to five times the net
profits
after everyone has been paid including
the manager
and so if the owner is working in the
business and is not paying themselves
out and creating the net profit and then
their only income is their net profit
you would insert a manager's salary
and reduce the net profit by that much
you see what i'm saying
yes i do so if i wanted to buy that from
nashville and someone else run it for me
turnkey
with someone else operating it and i'm
not over there making all the decisions
there's a good general manager running
the agency for me
uh what is the net profit then after i
paid them
and if the owner's operating in there
i'd have to that would be an extra
expense that's not in the current p l
does that make sense to you correct then
your net times your net profit times
after that your taxable income
times four
would be a 25 rate of return times five
would be a 20 rate of return
and you're going to want to make that at
least on a small business
because it's not going to be this never
turns out exactly like you think it's
going to turn out
and so that's not a that's a high rate
of return on a traditional investment
but a small business is a much more
risky investment
and so
if the thing's making a hundred grand
it's worth four to five hundred
max
max
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day jeremiah 31 25
i will i will refresh the weary
and satisfy the faint
philip brooks said i do not pray for a
lighter load but for a stronger back
careful there
that's the truth you'll get that one
answered
deborah's in gilbert arizona hi deborah
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much and thanks to your
ministry my husband and i
are everyday milli millionaires times
two way to go
for five years we've been completely
debt free my only regret is we were not
gazelle intense sooner would have
happened 10 years earlier well
congratulations we're proud of you how
can we help today well
thank you so i would like to gift our
daughter by paying off her mortgage and
my husband is reluctant to do that we
have
more than enough to do it without
changing any of our situation whatsoever
i would just like to do it as a gift for
our daughter what's the balance on her
about 130 okay you obviously have that
in cash out of your 2 million
and more okay all right
how is she with money
um she is very well um she does very
very well and she's been nothing but a
blessing to us her entire life
is she single
she is single she's 42 looking for mr
right if you know one send him our way
okay all right
why is your husband object
um he doesn't he doesn't have an
absolute reason he just thinks that we
shouldn't um it isn't monetarily because
we certainly can afford to do it and
um
he just just not knowing where this
world is going in the direction it's
going he's just reluctant to do so but
he can't really put his finger on why
okay
all right
well
people um that are cut from the cloth
that you guys are cut from i'm one of
you
um ken is too uh we believe in hard work
we believe in sacrifice to win and
that's how you've won
and he's afraid he's going to steal some
of that from her
possibly yeah
i just i would guess i mean that would
be a normal thing anyway
um and i would say to pay it off anyway
thank you now here's why
let's let me add a little bit to it in
his for his side of the equation and
we'll make it fun for everyone
i would ask her to sign a letter
not a formal document but just a letter
that you keep a copy of and she keeps a
copy of that promises that she will
never borrow money in her life ever for
anything
if you do this and
there is no question that she would do
that when she finds mr wright if he's a
financial planner we may have an
argument
she actually quit a job at a bank as a
teller because they were required to
sell so many credit cards a day yeah
well mr yeah mr wright could change her
mind i just i wanna i wanna just put
that out there so i just want something
in my file that she has in her file and
it was a little bit formal enough that
it sticks in her memory solid that that
mom paid off my house and i promised i'd
never borrow money again so we really
just can't borrow money if you're gonna
date me i just can't do it so um
i'm never borrowing money again and the
reason i wanted to do that is so that
she's gonna because she's going to
inherit five to ten million dollars
because your money's gonna double or
double two or three more times before
you die
um and
when she inherits all of that money we
want to keep her from screwing it up and
if she never borrows money again and
she's only in her 30s she's going to be
a multi-millionaire on her own
and so this is for her it's not for you
and
it is for your husband because here's
the sale to your husband if she agrees
to do that and then she invests a house
payment
in addition to what she's already
investing and she becomes wealthier than
you
earlier than you
uh you have literally changed your
family tree
with zeros on the end
and i think what you're saying hits the
nail on the head i think to some extent
on his point because i think he is
concerned that she might do that down
the road but i don't believe that she
would but putting it in writing prevents
that yeah it's not a contract and it's
not a it's just a communication piece
it's like it's like a um
an oath
i swear an oath
it's the debt-free oath
you know that kind of no questions
yeah it's an emotional thing
i would love to do this for you because
i know what it will do for you but it
won't do it for you unless you stay
debt-free and so part of me doing it for
you is you sign the debt-free oath or
whatever i mean make it make it corny i
don't care
i love that deborah dave uh deborah dave
i thought i heard you say
something to the effect of well the way
this world is right now he's not sure
which makes me also think that there's a
little bit of
he's worried that uh spending this money
could hurt them dave i hear a little bit
there's no chance of that yeah they're
in good shape yeah you've done well yeah
you're in good shape
i'm so proud of y'all and yes i would do
this we've got a lot of everyday
millionaires baby steps millionaires pay
off their kids houses but you don't want
to pay off a kid's house that's going
that you know they're doing cocaine and
so that gives them extra money for their
cocaine right you don't want to you
don't want to fund uh misbehavior
indirectly right
um and so it could be financial cocaine
it could be actual cocaine but i mean it
could be whatever so if they're out
there spending money like it's water
like they're in congress or something
then we're not going to give them more
to misspend that's that's just enabler
that's not a blessing but in your case
there's every reason here to do this and
i would do it and it helps you
emotionally to go okay this is the last
step of me changing my family tree
permanently very cool
ah frost is on the line in flint
michigan hi frost how are you
hey dave how are you thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
i had a career question for you uh my
wife is 24 i'm 30. we got married in
january and um congratulations about 80.
thank you together we make about 82 000.
um
i work we both work in uh sort of the
political uh part of the
part of the economy and
as i said i'm making about 40 and i just
didn't know what sort of advice you
would have for me
in pursuing other careers that could
expand my
my
income earnings
um so are you in campaign side of of
politics or working for a government
entity
campaign side yeah yeah uh i used to do
that by the way and so that you know
you're gonna you're not gonna have a
whole bunch of earning potential unless
you move into the consulting side of
that business which those folks can make
very good money
you know i think you've got to decide
what is it that you really want to do
you know do you want to step into more
political and government work or do you
want to eventually go to the private
sector or are you in a situation right
now where you're just going ken i need
to make more money what's the more
urgent question that you have
i just want to make more money okay
uh well so so right now if we're looking
to just make more money
i tell folks to focus on the talent side
of things i teach there's three elements
that every human has and that's where we
get ideas on what kind of work is really
meaningful and purposeful talent what we
do best passion work we love mission
results that we want our work to produce
for you in this situation if you're
trying to get out of debt or save some
money and begin to make a transition
focus on talent alone so you've got
skills and you've got some experience
that are transferable at the age of 30
correct
uh yes sir absolutely so we're looking
for okay i look at my skill set and
here's a fun little exercise homework
for you so you have a lot of confidence
in this decision i want you to just
write out what you think are your top
five to seven skills actual skills and
work you can also include people skills
in that list and then i want you to look
at the experience that campaign politics
has afforded you and write down your top
experience that you think is the most
transferable to other parts of the uh
workplace economy and then begin to look
at okay that gives me a really clear
indicator in what i do best which is
what i'm most marketable for and i'm
looking at job descriptions in flint
michigan that line up with that now i'm
also going to give you my get clear
career assessment hang on the line
kelly's going to give you a link to this
assessment it's a 20 25 minute
assessment it's going to allow you to go
deep on talent passion and mission give
you a purpose statement which becomes a
35 000 foot view
of the world at work and you can look at
multiple jobs that allow you to be on
purpose but i'd start with that talent
side of things because what this is
going to do for him dave is identify
jobs where he's qualified hot job market
increase that income immediately and put
that to work in the baby steps while
he's getting clear on a long-term play
kelly also gave him a copy of paycheck
to purpose skin's best-selling book get
clear assessments now blessed over 20
000 people have taken that
so if you want to know what you're up
for sign up for that it's a good deal
love it way to go that puts us our the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you